an exhibition in the heart of the
Ukrainian Capital featuring Russian
military equipment that was captured and
destroyed
hello I'm Adrian Finnegan in Kiev
Ukrainian forces have limited Russian
games in a year of conflict despite
moscow's Superior military Arsenal and
I'm Darian Abigail in Delhi Ukraine's
military tactics backed by Western
support have kept the war at a stalemate
but Moscow still controls about
one-fifth of the country you're watching
our special week-long coverage on Al
Jazeera of the Ukraine war one year on
foreign
Moscow has more soldiers weapons
aircraft and warships but has failed to
secure a decisive advantage over Kiev
Russia has replaced its military
leadership in Ukraine twice as it was
forced to retreat from territory it sees
in the early days of the conflict and
operating alongside the Russian military
is the mercenary Wagner group Wagner's
Frontline role has laid bare internal
tensions its founder yevne pagosian is
accusing the military leadership of
treason alleging they're holding back
ammunition the defense Ministry is
denied limiting supplies to the front
now Ukrainian forces fought off Russian
assaults on the capital cave in the
first few weeks of the conflict and the
West led by the U.S has scrambled to
expand Military Support heavily dipping
into their own stockpiles and this war
marks a turning point in the use of
combat drones for attacks as well as
surveillance private startups as well as
countries such as turkey and Iran have
become major suppliers
there's Fierce fighting around bakmut in
eastern Ukraine a city that Russia has
been trying to seize for more than six
months now now Moscow has intensified
its offensive while Kiev says it's
determined to hold its ground both sides
have described the battle for backwards
as the bloodiest of the war altazira's
Charles Stratford has been covering the
front bite extensively over the past
year he joins us now from some Michael
Square here in Kiev where those Russian
military vehicles are on show such as we
mentioned it's just one of several
contested battlefronts right now
foreign
that's right there are multiple
positions across that Eastern Front Line
where there is heavy fighting going on
but as you rightly said is often
described as being the most intense this
is somewhere that has been contested for
months by both sides we understand that
uh casualties on both sides have been
Extreme as well we also know that
approximately 5 000 civilians are still
inside
and they are refusing offers to be
evacuated the conditions that they're
living under are absolutely atrocious as
you can imagine and it was only I
suppose about a week ago now that the
Ukrainian military actually stopped
evacuees sorry evacuation teams
volunteers and Aid organizations from
going into bahmoud there's only one Road
in to the town now and we know that that
is coming under heavy shelling also
according to our sources The Village to
the south of it is called
it's taken was taken control of by the
Russians about a month ago and it's a
similar story now to the north west of
bakmut solidar was taken we've heard
today reports certainly according to the
Wagner group they saying that they have
taken a village called
which is to the north west of bakmut
Russian forces trying to surround that
City
also Big Flash points around the town of
liman now Lee man is further north than
mahmots it was a town that Ukrainian
military took back control of in the
late Autumn there hasn't been much
movement in that area until quite
recently it seems as if the Russians are
trying another counter-offensive but um
as I say these are only two places along
this front line where there is heavy
fighting ongoing there are big fears now
amongst Ukrainian officials and their
Western allies about what they describe
as a potential Spring offensive by the
Russians we've been looking at the
situation on the Battlefront since the
day of the invasion and this is our
report
on February the 24 2022 was the first
wave of Russian troops crossed the
border as Russian missiles Struck it
fast became clear that Vladimir Putin's
insistence that he would not invade
Ukraine had been a lie
it was a multi-pronged attack Russian
forces crossed from Belarus and advanced
towards cave there was a similar push in
the Northeast
and in the East towards Ukraine's Second
City kharkiv at the same time mainly
pro-russia separatist forces attacked
towns in ukrainian-controlled areas of
Donetsk and lugansk
Ukrainian president not yet in his
trademark military fatigues called for
help
I had a conversation with U.S President
Joe Biden the U.S is starting to gather
International support
poor planning and brave Ukrainian
defense quickly scaffolded Putin's
immediate plans to take give
Russian army columns were soon bogged
down and smashed
the enemy poorly calculated their
Communications and logistic needs and
their supply warehouses were across the
border this meant that after two days
they were stopped without fuel
ammunition and food and they lost the
effective management of their troops
on the 1st of April Ukraine announced it
had recaptured the entire region around
Kiev
dead civilians some with their hands
bound behind their backs were discovered
seemingly where they had been shot
Russia was accused of war crimes
the Russian army which Ukrainian
intelligence says had planned on taking
control of Kiev in three days had
suffered a historic and humiliating
defeat
in May after months of intense fighting
in the port city of mariopol the last
Romanian Ukrainian Fighters surrendered
at the azov style steel plant
what's there
but Ukraine by now is receiving what
would become tens of billions of dollars
worth of military aid
an Autumn counter-offensive liberated
tens of thousands of square kilometers
including the city of kerasan
preparations for the counter-offensive
started in April by June when we had
received Western weapons we were better
able to hit their supply lines command
centers and weapons and fuel Depots we
could also attack the reserved troops as
they approached the front line
him but since December Ukrainian gains
have slowed to a virtual standstill
Russia has made small advances in
eastern Don Mass using what Ukrainian
forces say is wave after wave of
infantry soldiers and mercenaries from
the Wagner group
some of the heaviest fighting continues
around the town of Bahamut where many of
the estimated 5 000 civilians Who Remain
there refuse to be evacuated
officials here in Kiev and their Western
allies are convinced that Russia is
about to launch what they describe as a
spring offensive more sophisticated
Weaponry such as tanks is on its way
from NATO countries but with no end in
sight to the fighting many are asking
just how long Ukraine's allies can fund
this war despite their leaders saying it
is a fight for democracy they cannot
lose Charles Stratford Al Jazeera Cube
well the U.S and its NATO allies have
promised dozens of Tanks to Ukraine at a
racing to replenish ammunitions spent on
the battlefield our defense editor Alex
katopoulos explains how Western Military
Support has helped Ukraine fight back
even before the war Ukraine was
receiving weapons from the West the
trickle of high-tech arms turning into a
flood when Russia invaded two weapons
types immediately stood out as having a
significant effect on the battlefield
powerful handheld anti-tank missiles
like the us-made javelin gave otherwise
lightly armed Ukrainian infantry the
ability to destroy Russian tanks as
Russia found out the hard way
an armed drones like the Turkish made
barracktar tb2 helped Ukraine spot
Russian armor columns a long way off
sending Vital Information back to
Ukrainian command posts allowing them to
guide long-range artillery fire onto the
targets and where possible destroy high
value targets of their own like radar
sights and command posts okay
in later months artillery became
important as both sides sought to grind
each other down in the donbass
NATO countries poured howitzers and
hundreds of thousands of rounds of
ammunition into Ukraine slowing Russia's
advances down to a snail's face
the arrival of long-range Precision fire
like the high Mobility artillery rocket
system or high Mars allowed Ukraine to
strike ammunition dumps and fuel storage
sites far behind the front lines
Staffing Russia's military of vital
supplies
for most of the war so far Ukraine had
leveraged Elon musk's starlink satellite
internet constellation not only keeping
commanders informed but guiding drones
to their targets in real time
however Starling has since banned
Ukraine from using the system for what
it calls offensive actions
air defense has played a key role in
protecting Ukraine's energy
infrastructure weapons like the National
Advanced surface-to-air missile system
or nassams have been vital for Ukraine's
defense with U.S Patriot batteries on
the way for Ukraine to go on the
offensive its military will have to
leverage the use of powerful main battle
tanks from the West like the UK's
Challenger 2 and Germany's Leopard 2
which will be used to punch holes in
Russian defensive lines
the arrival of advance to infantry
fighting Vehicles like the US Bradley
will help Ukrainian assault troops
crossing the Wide Open Spaces of the
Southern Ukrainian Countryside stay
protected as they go into action Alex
catopoulos altazira
well Ukrainian forces are being trained
to use Leopard 2 tanks in neighboring
Poland montessor's Jonah Hall reports
now from just show on how Poland has
become an outspoken voice pushing the
European Union of NATO to rapidly expand
support to Keith
lessons in how to operate a german-made
leopard 2 tank Ukrainian tank Crews have
come to Poland from the battlefields of
donetskuntlerhansk preparing for the
Handover of dozens of these much-needed
upgrades on their own failing Soviet era
fleets
at the moment we are very short of
armored vehicles and I hope that when we
get to the front line with this
equipment it will save a lot of lives of
our soldiers and bring us closer to
Victory
Poland has been at the Forefront of
efforts to better arm Ukraine's military
with vast quantities of hardware and
Munitions donated by NATO countries
funneled across polish territory much of
it via this U.S army base in the town of
Jesus close to the border with Ukraine
out here in eastern Poland the signs of
the marshalling of military aid for
Ukraine are clear you can literally see
them from the main road rows of Patriots
surface-to-air missile systems guarding
what is now a crucial Hub Hub and Poland
has been among the most vocal of
Ukraine's allies calling for stronger
support among those lobbying hardest is
former polish foreign minister radislav
Sikorski who says allies must now go
even further we are in our right to do
whatever it takes to help Ukraine defend
itself and Ukraine needs tax it needs
anti-aircraft missiles and it needs Jets
and there's very good reason why he care
is geography methods you know Poland is
actually the only country in NATO and
the European Union that has both Ukraine
and Russia as a neighbor
so we are you might say doubly a a a
Frontline state
these are lessons in how to take on the
Russians if all else fails many polls
believe that Ukraine is fighting Russia
so they don't have to but just in case
the Polish Army offers basic training to
civilians
well I think it's worth every citizen
knowing how these things work in case
something happens
definitely in the back of your head
there's always the fear that something
might happen I have a lot of colleagues
from Ukraine and this situation on our
eastern border is worrying
this is a country that feels the
proximity of Ukraine's war more than
most it's been more generous than most
in support perhaps because many feel it
has more to lose than most Jonah Hall Al
Jazeera jeshov Poland
well joining me now is Andre zagarodnik
who was Ukraine's defense minister from
2019 to 2020 and is now an advisor to
the government good to have you with us
sir are these Leopard 2 tanks and
Rockets that you've been promised enough
to make a difference on the battlefield
are they going to arrive in time to
counter any spring offensive or to be
part of of Ukraine's own spring tactical
plans well that's what we expect and
that's what we hope for but the question
is that each country has different
logistical arrangements and our job is
to make sure that they are hiring up as
much as they can if they're going to be
delaying then yes then we have then we
have a problem because basically it will
get us to the summertime and then you
know so that's why we we're all asking
our partners to speed up as much as they
can okay you're asking your partners but
you need what 300 or so tanks in order
to take back territory and you need them
fast I mean do you have faith in your
allies ability and perhaps their
willingness to follow through on this
promise yeah we do have a face we have
we believe that they have ability
question is how how quickly they can do
that the timing is basically our only
concern so far okay what else do you
need we talked about Rockets about tanks
you you need you're calling for for
airplanes as well yeah we're talking
about fighter jets of course but
basically this whole war is about
long-range Firepower so we need fighter
jets in order to deliver that fire power
to as as far as as we can encounter Uh
Russian positions and then also talking
about the um the multiple rocket
launches Rockets which would work for
150 kilometers U.S have developed them
together with Sweden and it's called uh
glsdb it's a ground line small diameter
bomb which works for 450 kilometers
there's been a political decision to
provide it again question now is only
about timing I will make a substantial
difference do you think though that your
allies will follow through on it I mean
they they do a lot of talking uh and
they've made these promises but then
they that they seem not to be able to
deliver on time but I mean it must be
pretty frustrating from your point we
have seen of course there's been
concerns about timing we have seen that
whatever they promised usually they
delivered so question only about them
not to delay things and of course the
tanks are very difficult machines I mean
they're very complex so they need
technical support they need spares and
so on uh providing those in time that's
also critical because capability is not
just a piece of equipment at some point
of time it's actually you know a
technical support as well so yeah that's
that's that is complex but we believe we
can resolve that okay many thanks indeed
I'm afraid we're gonna have to leave it
there thank you yeah okay yeah that's it
for now
thank you Andre Sagara Former Defense
Minister advisor to the government here
in Kiev now among the ukrainians on the
front lines are an increasing number of
women it wasn't always that way I met a
young mother who served as a sniper and
was the only woman in her unit of 400.
in the beginning they were a bit
uncertain because here in Ukraine it's
not normal to have a woman in the Army
and so when I joined up I understood
that I needed to prove myself that I
could be their equal and after a month
they'd accepted me the Ukrainian Army
doesn't have
uniform for women does it I mean how
does a woman cope on the front line oh
no I was on the front line from the
beginning of the full-scale invasion I
was given a men's uniform and I adjusted
it myself I found a sewing shop in one
town that was under occupation and they
helped me but we don't have that problem
anymore in Ukraine they're now
manufacturing women's uniforms recently
I donated 412 uniforms to women who are
serving on the front line so right now
the girls are more lucky than I was back
then how did your family feel about you
going to fight you you already have an
11 year old daughter right and how did
it feel for you leaving her in the
beginning it was really important to
make sure my daughter was safe and so I
did that first when it started at five
in the morning I organized for her to be
taken to Western Ukraine and into Poland
I didn't see her for a long time it was
very hard obviously it was the best
thing to do at that time
my mom and my close friends were shocked
when I said I was going to the front
that I was going to fight I will never
forget their faces when I told them I
was going to war my mum looked at me and
I said everything will be okay I'll meet
a man there I'll get married everything
will be all right and that happened
the reason you're not on the front line
now is because as we can see you're
expecting a baby you met your husband on
the front line tell me about that ah
duck yes I don't know imagine I didn't
meet the love of my life when I was a
civilian I met him on the front line
we met online actually on social media
at that time I was quite famous in
Ukraine there were a few articles
written about me so he saw them and
messaged me he said that he was very
proud of a woman like me he's a soldier
as well who was serving in a different
region in a different division so the
war brought us together and soon our
baby will be born
and
when the movie is born would you
consider going going back to fight
I hope that by that time the war will be
over however as Yoda said in Star Wars
the future is foggy we'll see what will
happen if necessary I'll go however
right now I have a maternal Instinct and
I know that I'm more useful here at home
than on the front line I'm still
fulfilling my Civic duties I'm doing
volunteer work I'm 34 weeks pregnant and
I still haven't had a rest when I give
birth we'll see why as a woman
is it so important to you to be part
of this of this fight
it doesn't matter if you're a man or a
woman or how much money you have if you
want to and you're able to defend your
country you should do it
now drones have become an important part
of Ukraine's Arsenal often enabling it
to outmaneuver a much larger Russian
military more on that now from Darin in
Doha yes Adrian well Russia has
responded by turning to Iran for a
low-cost drones some of them have
slipped past Ukraine's defenses our
defense editor Alex katopoulos explains
foreign
massive missile inventory is running
seriously low a year of high intensity
conflict has all been exhausted stocks
as it launched missile strike after
missile strike when Ukraine's past
structure and high value military
targets
to replace these depleted stocks Moscow
has turned to one of its few friends
Iran who agreed to export massive
amounts of its shahead 136 drone
cheap and accurate the shahead is
launched in salvos technically a drone
is being used by Russia as a cruise
missile it can fly hundreds of
kilometers and has an 80 kilogram
Warhead
in return for this help Russia has
agreed to give Iran 24 of its advanced
suhoi su-35 fighter jets which will make
a valuable addition to Iran's Antiquated
Air Force
Russia has showered its targets for
these drones Slow and Low flying many
have been shot down but enough get
through to cause significant damage to
Ukraine's power structure weaponizing
the cold and plunging many parts of the
country Into Darkness Alex catopoulos Al
Jazeera
now the central role played by the
Wagner mercenary group and the assault
on eastern Ukraine has exposed tensions
with regular Russian forces Osama bin
Javed is joining us from Moscow so what
are we to make of the tensions between
the Wagner group and the Russian forces
susama
thank you
well it has been the tip of the spear so
to speak in the Eastern parts of Ukraine
where it has been taking territory
gradually uh taking a lot of casualties
and been providing the cover that the
Russian military needed to carry out
these operations but in the last few
days we've heard repeatedly from evgeny
pregozian the leader of Wagner group
saying that the military bureaucracy has
had its hands tied uh they're not
providing enough equipment enough
ammunition and that seems to be a
problem on the front line so there seems
to be frustration from the head of the
Wagner group that he is not able to
penetrate further deeper into Ukrainian
territory and has been taking steady
losses also he's no longer able to
recruit prisoners who were able to come
in serve for three months and get their
sentence communicated so this is going
to be an interesting spring push if it
comes to that where Wagner seems to be
on the front end and is pushing forward
as just today it's been provided with a
train according to Wagner of weapons and
Munitions right and and Osama there are
concerns in Russia about about it
rapidly using up munitions
so this has been a war as military
experts have said that this has been a
war of long-range
weapons and that includes Rockets
artillery uh long-range guns and
everything else so all of that requires
a lot of Munitions according to
estimates by the summer there were about
000 rounds being used by both sides
according to conservative estimates each
day that number has significantly gone
down but it just goes to show that how
much Firepower they need and on the
Ukrainian side they need a plethora of
these because they're working with old
Soviet equipment as well as new modern
infrastructure that has been provided
and the Russian side they have been
delving into their old stocks and some
Ukrainian experts say that now the
Rockets and the shells that are landing
in their territory are very new some
that have been manufactured as as near
as October Osama bin Javed thank you so
much while joining me live on Skype from
Paris is Samantha debender and she's an
associate fellow in the Russia and
Eurasia program at Chatham House welcome
to Al Jazeera so despite fight Moscow
having more soldiers more weapons and
more aircraft why do you think it hasn't
secured a decisive win over Kiev yet
well because the the first rule of war
is that if you're fighting uh if you're
an invading Army and you are fighting a
very motivated Army on the other side
then you're gonna have to make a very
very big offensive Putin was not
prepared to see the resilience of the
Ukrainian people and this resilience was
actually evident even before the Western
weapons came in massively there's a very
interesting example of a town called
Sumi which is in northeastern Ukraine
where the actual Ukrainian Army had
withdrawn in the very early days of the
invasion last year and the Russia Army
was not able to take the town because
the territorial defense put up such a
fight the Russian army thought that
Ukraine had its best troops in this town
in fact they were civilians who were
defending the town right so there has
been a
the West giving Ukraine military aid and
how do you explain that the fact that
the West has given Ukraine billions in
military aid yet Ukraine itself has lost
a fifth of its country to Russia
well first of all uh the war has been
going on since 2014 that is nearly nine
years and most of the territory that
Russia had conquered was actually
conquered in the
2014-2015 period the ukrainians since
they have had Western weapons have taken
back 50 of the territory that Russia had
conquered including some of the
territory that had been conquered in the
in the 2014-2015 attacks so I would say
the Western weapons have been decisive
and have been have around allowed the
ukrainians to miraculously regain
territory that would have been
impossible to do without these Western
weapons
all right we'll leave it there thank you
so much Samantha de bender and for
speaking to us from Paris we appreciate
your time
you're welcome
now both Ukraine and Russia have been
extensively using drones and as Gabriel
Elizondo reports from New York smaller
U.S arms manufacturers are in the
Forefront of that technology
it's one of the smallest most lethal and
lesser-known weapons currently being
deployed in Ukraine the switchblade 300
is a drone that is lightweight and
highly sophisticated you've got your
cameras up here you've got your eoir
sensor the munition or explosive device
is embedded inside the Drone the whole
device is designed to fly into the
Target and explode like this
but what makes it unique is patented
technology that allows a soldier
controlling it on the ground to change
plans in mid-flight they can what we
call wave off go off the target go back
to another safe point and re-engage a
different Target maybe the same Target
at a later Point all of these are really
amazing capabilities for the person the
war fighter that's operating the
switchblade that they don't get in a
normal munition
videos from Ukraine show its
Effectiveness against Russian positions
the United States sent several hundred
to Ukraine in the early stages of the
war Ukraine has credited the switchblade
for helping repel Russian advances
the switchblade is made by aerovirament
a california-based weapons maker the
company is one of numerous smaller
lesser-known arms makers signing
contracts with the Pentagon there's a
special program to encourage companies
to create experimental systems that can
be used in Ukraine and to do it quickly
and sometimes the smaller companies are
more Nimble the war in Ukraine is
believed to be the first time the
switchblade has been used in a
large-scale military conflict the maker
of the weapon says many potential
customers who they won't identify have
inquired about placing orders after
seeing it in use in Ukraine it's now
much better known what the switchblade
can bring so with renewed interest or
with new interest we are certainly
meeting the demands that are coming
towards us
the Ukraine conflict becoming a
real-life testing ground for new
Munitions some of which have rarely ever
been used in war but now increasingly in
high demand
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York
that's it for me on the military aspects
of the war but make sure you tune in on
Friday that's February 24th we Mark the
first anniversary of the world with
special newshours at 11 GMT and 16 GMT
thank you